- So you sing opera, right?
You were in an opera, right?
Did, did you actually end up performing?
- Sometimes I put skis on
and I go down a mountain,
but that doesn't make me a skier.
You know what I mean?
So--
- Yes I do.
That's me in a snowboard.
(laughing)
- So I can carry it tune.
You know, I had,
I had a weird stammer when I was a kid
and I had a music teacher
who helped me with that.
And through music,
I sort of discovered some
things about myself that I,
that I didn't know.
- Yeah.
- And so when I,
when I decided to try
and get into the entertainment business,
the opera represented a loophole.
Like if you can get into the opera,
you have your AGMA card,
your American Guild of Musical Artists,
and that lets you buy your
Screen Actors Guild card.
What I needed was my
Screen Actors Guild card,
but I couldn't get hired
to work in television
because I wasn't part of the union
and I couldn't get in the union cause
I hadn't worked in television.
- I, it's such a weird thing, I know.
- It's stupid,
but
(laughing)
the way in for me was
to learn the shortest aria I could find
and crash an audition
for the Baltimore Opera
and just sing it as loud as I could
and hope that they needed
young guys with low voices.
And somehow they let me in
and I figured I would stay
for a performance or two,
you know, maybe half a season,
but the music was better than I thought
and the girls were like everywhere.
(laughing)
- Like everywhere and
and, y'all are outnumbered so.
(laughing)
- I mean.
- That's awesome.
I love first of all,
cause I've sang arias before
and I grew up singing
operatic stuff all the time.
So I love that you were just like, sure,
I'll find an aria
and I'll walk into an
audition and nail it.
- True story.
- That is bold.
- I went to Rosedale Public Library
and I said to the librarian, I said, look,
I'm gonna try and force
my way into the opera,
although that was before Forest Gump.
I said, I'm gonna fake it you know?
But give me something
simple that I can memorize.
So it was a La bohème
it was the coat aria
and I walked around Baltimore
in like 1984 with a walkman on my head,
listening to Samuel Ramey,
sing it over and over.
I didn't know what the words meant.
I just memorized the
sounds and the melody.
- Yeah.
- And that's all I knew
when I, when I went in.
- Gosh, that's, I mean, that's insane.
That's a gift.
Just, you know, like not everybody--
- You did the same.
I mean, what was American Idol?
You know.
- No, but I'm just saying,
but I was trained far before that,
like not in pop singing,
but I just mean, in
in like singing,
like I was used to audition.
I was used to like from childhood.
So like that was,
that was a different thing.
That was not,
that was way more bold what you did,
but Mike, I want it.
I don't want to put you on the spot,
but I'm gonna,
like you can say no,
but I kind of want to hear you sing opera
'cause your voice has such beautiful tone.
Can you sing something.
- LJ? You want me to sing something?
- Yeah brother.
- Yes!
- All right, I'm gonna hit
you with a little Italian.
This is the audition.
This is the beginning
of the audition piece.
I had no idea what the words meant.
I learned them later,
but this is what got me
into the Baltimore Opera.
(clearing throat)
- Okay.
(singing in Italian)
- Oh my gosh your tone is magical!